[Music]
in wrong place news
Ono submitted by sugar and spice makes
everything nice a man who tried to rob a
pizzeria got beaten down by the stuff
yes yes Bharat that's what I want to
hear I love I just I love like violence
so I was really excited about this I
already saw the dessert I love criminals
getting there's a compilation video
[Laughter]
[Applause]
sorry let's talk about the article this
is mostly just like a video it is
burners so there's not a lot of details
on this there's no police report filed
because they beat this dude's ass so bad
that they just let him go home you I
would do that that's what I would yeah
so I I'm gonna cut you guys like
straight to like the meet the me-80
but so basically the way to clip starts
as this dude walks in he's masked he's
got a gun there's a woman at the front
counter and you there's no audio but
she's you know she's obviously like oh
[ __ ] you know kind of scared and starts
looking around and I guess maybe she
tells him like I can't get to the money
right away or something you've got to
get this or I've got to do something so
they're kind of dilly-dallying around
but finally she opens up the register
and she's not alone there's two other
employees in the store don't tell me
there's a video oh yeah oh there's a
video oh there's a video god I wish I
could watch this with you guys
silence oh [ __ ] is it working
no okay damn all that build-up alright
here we go
what's the spacebar I tried oh all right
here we go give me your money
I know there's something underneath
there absolute it's so much better home
swiftly limo dude he's and he's just
like he's yeah he didn't get her quote
to get in and then once he starts to
move a little bit you'll see that
there's blood all over the floor
yeah that's a lot of blood he [ __ ]
this dude Oh butt cheek how come there's
always butt cheeks every time Ackerman
who tries to rob some [ __ ] his pants
falls down yeah
so they [ __ ] this guy up so bad they
probably didn't want to call the police
because this was like this is almost
unnecessary for us but boy do we I mean
okay you're right now his hand on his
gun what did he not let go of the gun he
takes so yeah so they've got the gun I
think they've got the gun now he's like
you one more time yeah that was really
good so this is I like this part so he
chases him out he's got his own gun he's
got he's got the dude's gun he shuts the
gate and then he's just like Mme
so what I saw took him down and a minute
you take him down he got side control
from side control so there's this thing
he does he posted if you guys pay
attention he post his left knee outside
of this guy's right thigh so he can't
turn against him so he's stuck in that
position and now he just starts pounding
them in the face yes I wanna date him
why you want to see the dash again
we can watch the dash again know what I
appreciate a good can't watch too much
violence because I get too excited I
want to stop somebody in the mouth now
if he actually trains on the main like
he most fast he's like okay here's Mike
here's my chance he doesn't write when
the guy moves he so Hoshi passes his
guard side control his knees against
that guy's thighs are punching okay let
me get a better position oh man
what's up anger frustration that thing
is like [ __ ] yeah make my day like it
didn't even faze him I he always gonna
at the door he like I get [ __ ] lots
get [ __ ] lunch at the gate and it's
like we're off for the night okay so the
bad guy with a gun in his hand he put it
in his waistband that's where it was
perfect timing
oh okay cuz I will not attack a dude
with a gun in his hand
yeah this is too [ __ ] risky what was
in the envelope right then he reached
into the register and that guy when it's
so fast is so hard
you like violence no but like I like a
man that attacked me how about that
kills another person with his bare hands
[Laughter]
a lot of self-control because at that
point I think I would start stopping on
his mouth to break every single teeth
dude I think he did Lucy because I'm
wondering how he lost blood so quickly I
would try I would smash his head like a
Cheadle puff on the [ __ ] playground
floor you a soccer game in the face that
was like that was like oh that was like
top five beat downs for me I still say
it's my number one though is when that
woman got slapped on the train like when
I see like when I see like impact
violence she's like trying to act tough
I didn't that guys just leave me alone
and he just goes wow I like I don't like
violence
I like justice violence yes
satisfying yeah it is and like you know
that lady on the train she needed to get
slapped God and he got embarrassed he
will never rob another place again like
he literally won't you might I don't
think so because that he got mugged
Ramat Isaac there's so much blood I was
just thinking about that I feel like I
was way too excited about that no that's
tight
I love violence too we're in the same
club just violence I like justice
violence just as violence I like all
kinds but I got a I got a in doses no I
don't like all kinds I can't do all
copies all right like we had there was
one video we're like we were doing where
the woman got like bit on arm and like I
couldn't even I couldn't even watch what
like it was like a lady that got bit by
her she got clawed by a tiger Oh [ __ ]
selfie yeah see that's just as one spy
with a pen barrier yeah I got a lion or
a Jaguar close or just scary like this
you want to take a selfie and she like
went past the barrier did this and the
thing just say my justice violence what
kind of violence made me sad Haram be
really be one gun violet the only animal
I don't like animals getting hurt oh I
love gun violence I love animals getting
hurt no no it's all about the justice
right you just wanted to play with the
kid I liked when I like I like when
people are doing things that they're not
supposed to do because the thing is a
lot of times people are allowed to just
do whatever the [ __ ] they want and they
don't get served like they don't get
checked so I line like as a person that
like I used to
it was almost like part of me to bring
justice to people like if somebody was
lying about some [ __ ] like I will
[ __ ] call you out or like you know if
something happened like I will be the
one to hit you like straight up but as
I've gotten older I realized that like I
don't need to create that drama for
myself I don't need to put myself in
those situations I don't need to stick
my neck out for like stuff that's not my
problem
so I love
because you are spite you know what that
means
you're a spiteful person but you want a
reason to bully somebody that's what
you're doing I can agree and barf bucket
did this [ __ ] too but when I was in
elementary you had the peacekeepers
where you want to justify your beef man
these guys fight for justice [ __ ] these
guys they're all like your bad guys and
gay so I'm gonna [ __ ] them up and I'm
like but you're the one [ __ ] all up
at parties for no reason what's he
keeping the peace he's like I'm the good
guy cuz I'm doing it without a gang name
these guys are different he didn't have
a gang name peacemaker but they did you
know what I thought it was next level
though I was like you guys are honorable
like you guys are keeping the peace
through violence he's all the peace yeah
yeah yeah Wow I would do this like I
would look for guys that are bigger than
me like in fifth grade or whatever right
and I'd be like oh this guy's big so he
probably bullied someone so I'm gonna
bully him just to let him know not to
[ __ ] with little guys but usually I have
no evidence that he's a bully I'm just
thinking he is because he's big just
like this so I'm like before you go and
[ __ ] up little guys I'm just gonna [ __ ]
you up right now so it does sound like
you were bullying people I know but
that's how stupid I was I saw what you
did the same thing my friend no I think
okay I'm trying to think of like what my
terms of peacekeeping art like I would
be the one I would be the one to like I
don't know okay so it was a mean girl
and you would confront her because she
was being mean to everybody no no no
okay actually it's at one time I've told
this story a few times it was this girl
her name was Louisa I was walking out of
the arcade
Louisa called me the n-word I turned
around I was like what you say like you
know I speak for my people I was like
Williams
what no she was Hispanic and she beat
the [ __ ] out of me father's back she
doesn't go the right way
oh my god she literally she had one of
those bangles the like the bracelets I
feel like I don't know if I've told this
before she had this bracelet she flipped
it over her fist and was just ready
it was bang [ __ ] I was like all right
and like and shoe and then like I still
remember she was punching me she was
like I thought you wanted to fight [ __ ]
Luisa got four kids now we don't made up
we fought each other like I think she
follows me on Instagram I think I talked
about it you know I was like can we go
say thank you and go but like that
that's the kind of [ __ ] that I would get
like involved and you know I had to be
the justice bringer there now are you
always watching that's Superman's I got
his ass beat
then if you use racial slurs you can
beat somebody up and insert their top
minute Oh
mall security dragged me out and they
and they were like they were like this
is this is so serious like they dragged
me out and I was bleeding from my face
and they were like they were like well I
guess we know who won that fight and I
was like yeah she popped my pimple
that's so beat up I feel like you sure
win that [ __ ] and I was like all [ __ ]
up they banned me from the mall like
they had it on video I want that video
just for my good
[Music]